I also go press welcome to another in
real life episode you read suggested
that for this week we're gonna do
Powerpuff Girls I wanted them to have a
bit of a creepier feel to them so I'm
probably gonna do it a bit differently
the Cata reminds me of Spice Girls what
if we use the Spice Girls as original
Gary is that is that Gary Gary spice
girl she's the orange one right okay we
found a great picture amazing BAM okay
well it appears her head needs to be the
shape of a football so let's let's do
that
[Music]
that looks great already para para para
Peck
let's start by removing everything
horrifyingly enough this looks like you
I love this alright the eyes oh my god
the eyes this is gonna be the creepiest
picture ever how the hell I'm gonna make
it step yeah big particulate yeah that
looks that looks great thank you
it's not creepy at all
[Music]
disgusting alright now for the the mouth
do that her body needs to be a lot
smaller let's try and do that Terry
piscis
Parris cares oh no she has banks dammit
yep that was worth the extra effort
looks like [ __ ] awesome
fit I feel like she's staring into my
soul I don't know what it is alright
let's find the blondie this was my
favorite Spice Girl when I was a kid
okay Wow let's turn her face into a
football cuz that's my job now
apparently it looks so good just like
that at least that looks just like the
pictures all right let's get rid of our
stupid face I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm if
you're watching this video that your
face is not stupid maybe a little bit
I like it better just like that it's so
much better let's do the hair hair needs
to be more blonde which doesn't seem to
be [ __ ] working she needs to wear a
blue shirt [ __ ] yep that looks like a
body I love the eyes so much perfect
hundred percent accuracy alright let's
make her head into a football again our
dress needs to be green though damn it
but I'm putting my heart and soul into
this so please don't criticize me
because I am very sensitive
parapa scares I left half risk is how do
we do her hair bam bam boom but BAM wow
it's almost like I can't tell any
difference except their arms I didn't
really nail the arms today ya know they
kind of look like that beautiful ten out
of ten would powerpuff anytime any day
of the week Sun any day of the week
let's do some final detail work
art this is art and there you have it
pressed Powerpuff Girls in real life
what has been seen anyway bros if you
enjoyed this video please hit that like
button comment and let me know what what
else what other childhood memories you
want me to ruin for you that's all for
me for now thank you for watching and as
always stay on this great terrifying as
always just what I wanted more
nightmares your the notes